[موسيقى]
وتيره الحركه في الشارع العراقي هدات بعض
الشيء اليوم مثل ما هو الحال عموما عشيه
توقع اي حرب وجه وزير الخارجيه ناجي صبري
رساله الى الامين العام للامم المتحده وفي
عنان اتهمه فيها بتسهيل الاعتداء على
العراق على الرغم الاستعدادات القائمه
للحرب والاعلان عن قبول التحدي فانا
العراقيين في نهايه المطاف يتمنان بالفعل
ان لا تقع تلك الحرب
[موسيقى]
فقاتلوهم ايها الاخوه
واضربوهم في الليل والنهار
[موسيقى]
قوات الامريكيه خلفت وراها طابورا طويلا
من القتل والدمار والجثث المتفهمه مهرا
لدخول بغداد الخادم محمد المهدي العربيه
من طريق جسر الرشيد
العربيه بغداد
[موسيقى]
في اول ظهور له عرض تنظيم داعش خطبه صلاه
الجمعه لزعيمه ابو بكر البغدادي
احال الرئيس الوزراء نوري المالكي على
تقاعد كلا من قائد القوات البريه الفريق
اول الركن علي غيدان وقائد الشرطه
الاتحاديه الفريق الركن محسن الكعبي قاده
التحالف الوطنيه يدعون للتعجيل بحسم مرشحي
الرئاسات الثلاث في العراق والملكى يبدي
تمسكه بمنصب رئيس الحكومه نعلن النصر
المؤزر طول العراق رسميا صفحه داعش
الدمويه
[موسيقى]
تظاهرات في بغداد احتجاجا على الفساد تخلف
قاتلين ومئتين جريح
والحب طالب
التلفزيون العراقي الرسمي اعلن مقتل ابو
مهدي المهندس وايضا قاسم سليماني اكدت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه في بين لها مقتل
قائد فيلق القدس قاسم سليماني لم يحدث
عمليه تحدي جديده للمرور
هذه كانت اخر كلمات هشام الهاشمي تتواصلوا
ردود الفعل العراقي والدوليه الممدده
باغتيال المحلل الامني والمستشار السابق
في الحكومه العراقيه هشام الهاشمي
البرلمان العراقي امنح الثقه لحكومه
الكاظم والاخير يقول ان حكومته وحكومته
حلا وليست حكومه ازمات
اذا مشاهدينا اقتحامات للمباني الحكوميه
بحسب المصادر الطبيه التي تواصلنا معها
هذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل زواياه
والليله تحديدا من العراق نشاهد عمليه
اطلاق في اسلحه متوسطه مرحبا بكم ضيوفي
الكرام
[موسيقى]
يدخلون هنا الى المنطقه الخضراء نعم ميسون
تحيه مجددا خلال 60 دقيقه اذا لم ينسحب
حتى من الاعتصام امام البرلمان فانا ابرع
حتى من السياره